the creatures of the deep are hard to
fathom that's because collecting them
takes equipment like nets and suction
tubes which can injure the delicate
animals now scientists have come up with
a kinder gentler way of handling these
creatures inspired by the mechanisms
that move kids toys and even our own
hands
researchers from the VESA Institute at
Harvard University invented a prototype
gentle mechanical hand that can safely
capture deep-sea creatures the device is
composed of two-dimensional shapes that
fold to create a three-dimensional
enclosure think of it like origami where
a single piece of paper can be shaped
into a crane or a ball only in this case
the shapes and folds are predicted
mathematically the prototype had five
main panels that are comprised of two
smaller panels all the panels are
connected to a central link that's
controlled by a rotary actuator this
coordinates the panels so they can be
folded together at the same time by
closing fingers into a fist and similar
to our hands this device is also
attached to an arm which can be mounted
on an underwater vehicle and controlled
remotely the grabber can dive deep while
scientists watch safely from their ship
not only is it safe for the researchers
whether it's safe for sea creatures as
well that's because of the soft silicon
edges of the panels the scientists can
stop the cage from closing at any time
as they can watch its progress by video
future versions of the device might
include sensors that can measure in
organisms vitals or a 3d scanner that
can reveal how their bodies act
differently at these depths compared to
the low pressure surface given its
simple design the mechanical hand might
one day be kitted up for work in outer
space perhaps is a way of manipulating
solar panels to power satellites but for
now
this device is already lending a hand to
deep-sea research
[Music]
[Music]